foreign
like I said nailed by itself I'm trying
to lose weight man it's about time I
wasn't gonna say anything I'm getting
fat you ever have it on like a brownie
like a warm brownie oh [ __ ] you I love
warm Brown
you guys did
you dip yeah
of course what are you doing what the
hell is that dip
I thought you just ate one of those
I'm out
I've done it twice in my life yeah it's
the only tobacco product that's ever
made me throw up oh yeah I'm making you
sick it makes you dizzy
you're a dip guy that takes his dip job
person right
what do you mean it takes it still
probably like if you're at the movie
theaters
[Laughter]
do you leave do you leave your dip jar
behind are you just spitting into the
straw too yeah that's actually the
classiest way I've ever seen it right
right because I think this is
it just went
yep four is it good [ __ ] you Hans you go
first yeah so you're last
so who goes first you didn't roll an
eight
that was quick that was a really quick
one good job guys
this is the wrong thing wow you can
really see the board what are you even
talking about it's light in here
what you mean lit
light yeah your grammar was terrible
there sorry I'm illiterate
it's okay all right Farm Boy
do you know the life of shooting sweet
Jades
work yeah I need a one of those cards to
tell you what to buy I'm sorry it's been
a little bit I didn't mean to
simplifying like that yourself oh no I'm
just a simple farmer
that's what I tell girls and they get
mad at me
oh she's so cute
do you have uh the car let's see
I had the what for the resources I'm
even
this is for you
there's I'll I'll get it okay
I'm looking at the spot and I hope you
don't take it every time we should do I
see my other spot that I'm going to take
thank you
where's the bong at
Gareth hit it in his corporate shame why
do you have a bomb next to you Gareth
corporate put it behind the corporate B
well I mean we weren't smoking you know
we were just smoking CBD yeah you don't
have to worry about the law or anything
because we're White
we're playing Catan for God's sake are
you worried about the man I thought
America was supposed to be the land of
the free no I kind of scared you are
so scared
oh my God
what am I doing boy
in fact put me down as Foghorn Leghorn
when you post this
is the first thing it populates whenever
you look up My Name by the way yeah
obviously no it's no it's because my
name is
I'm already up yeah
all right when it's his turn we had to
stop talking
they can only do one thing at a time we
need to whenever he just turn something
needs a pop-up behind his head that says
Foghorn Leghorn
the brain of a fog
you know the Frog what does it stand for
bad things
it's your turn
still
I guarantee you're still good oh I
started talking to him this is the first
time it's been on camera this is awesome
that is so cool
reminds me science [ __ ] it reminds me
of that fat guy from um Star Wars
no idea why oh yeah the fat guy from
Star Wars The Guy Jabba the Hutt yeah I
don't know why
David sent to fonte no oh the the thingy
I don't know
no I mean uh maybe it's the guy that's
next to him with the little wrap around
he's got a little head tail oh yeah
Garrett do you want to smoke some no I
don't do that dude
so what a [ __ ] what are you talking
about man stop it
foreign
look at all this free weed I get to
smoke good job man
do you need to take a pee break I'm
[ __ ]
certificating
please use smaller words indicated in
your life
I'm haunted because
I'm glad you can amuse yourself it was
funny it was horrible
no I know and we all know what I should
do I'm calling time
yeah this is your second settlement okay
pick up your second settlement
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] place your
[ __ ] dude come on five four no
one zero [ __ ] [ __ ] you man no one
cares about you nobody cares about you
uh like you went with the worst spot oh
you already you already released
what an idiot shut up we can literally
make him do anything you purposely
knew what you were doing [ __ ] you David
he's a dick you [ __ ] salted
[ __ ] salty Jesus
this is too aggressive they are
aggressive oh my God all right I'm done
all right ridges I mean uh Gareth is
already bending the rules in his favor
oh [ __ ] typical Trump supporter
these are horrible numbers for
for wheat what
hmm
what do the most
huh
so the national Catan championships
happen and some New Zealand guy won
yeah yeah I bet you I can beat him
I can all be there has he
is he like I have the heart of the cards
on my hand was it Garrett Bale's score
poured up to all the Garretts I'm not a
fan of whales so I'm just a fan of
Bulgaria you don't like have to
represent she doesn't do animal joke you
don't like sea creatures
so wait what happened in the soccer is
it my turn uh we tied the US Thai so
what's that mean we tie with the nation
with the population of less than like a
couple million people
we have 300 million people that's so
that's terrible I mean we had hope this
year and I thought it was hilarious that
people thought that we had a chance to
go to the World Cup
so dumb we're in the World Cup dummy I
mean to Win It to Win It nobody thought
that
yeah there's all these ads with John
Hamm looking good as hell they're trying
to pay him oh my God he's just like you
know why did you do that that's so funny
it is funny isn't it yeah
it's like I don't have any sheep
but I'm gonna build on the sheep port
it's just to bug you and I love it
have
happened
oh man you took did you pick up the
second settlement they're too wheat no
pick it up [ __ ]
this is the difference between you
playing in real life and we're just a
couple of nerds on one because
I don't follow those books no idea what
he's gonna do it's a wild card yeah I
hate that okay I'll put the robber on a
two
where no one's at oh
just to be nice
wow we're all congregated over there oh
it's all where the high numbers are at
least we were able to do a little bit
now
you guys are the high numbers
eight eight
four dude
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
I got you Derek Poston in the basement
and Brian Simpson and Sam Lopez they're
responding very viscerally to the big
screen okay
I have a weekend report has anybody been
watching Andor
no yeah Pandora's awesome [ __ ] watch
it that's my synopsis
Bridge just got cut off
eight
wait Dave Woodrow a roll of five would
anyone like to trade a wheat
for
something
a brick
a sheep I'll give you sheep
I'll give it to Garrett Gareth
this is some East-West drive already
they're they're on the side now because
they're on the same side of the table
is anyone
again your exposure effect I'll do it
again I'm good just being close to
someone makes you like them more
it's the Law of Attraction because it's
like I gotta trust them to not murder me
right now so you gotta be nice to them
yeah
but you and I don't have that connection
eight again Jesus there's a table
between us
table is a symbol civilizing Force oh
you should get a piece of paper with all
the numbers on it and I'll tell you how
it's nice to statistically see what
numbers are rolling that's what the Hans
heads are for oh that's what they do
yeah okay great they say who's smoking
some good
this is much better than listening to
Red Band
[Laughter]
I've just read it
good stuff dude hey if you want me to
hit another bong hit give me a super
sticker
who said that your nose turns white when
you laugh what someone said that your
nose turns white when you laugh just
mine yeah
oh it does look at that a little bit his
whole face
is red he's white as [ __ ] he's got a
tomato
face dude I'm calling you tomato face
nine nine oh I rolled an eight
this is
three
just 99 unemployed smoker sent me 99
good job dude
represent
I gotta take a bong hit already
I mean for the foreign
going on
what in tarnation nine nine nine again
try to resist your stupid urges
anybody's seen downfall before
doing downfall this guy in this movie
downfall is okay this guy is two roads
nobody's trying to do that no I know
that's why it's so nobody else should be
with that does Hitler like a perfect
place
he lives in Germany he's a German actor
must be terrible he used to go down this
street can I take it back to him can I
just do one run
what did you put in there yeah you never
put it down yet okay
[Music]
[Music]
your sense of Purity is out of whack
you have to put him in the right order
no no
what is the right order we
no wheat sheep sheep is the least
valuable
oh it goes most to least then from left
right
I was wrong yeah you are wrong
it's definitely more valuable yeah yeah
it was a bit late
yeah man it wasn't live right now
and again
that's how you brought that movie up
well no I watched it the other day and I
was like dude this is
this guy is here seven count them up
so what is your favorite thing about
Hitler
really
like that
oh this seems like a trap
well you just talk a lot about Hitler I
just thought you had some opinions
did you ever watch Indiana Jones
the third one hell yeah the writers of
the Lost are yeah I don't know is it not
Raiders of Lost Ark is it the final per
se is that all you're gonna do Dave did
you watch her did you ever watch any of
the other Jones films Raiders is
incredible Ranger's incredible he wants
break I like the third one the best
who wants Rock
I do what do you want for sheep no
uh don't crack your knuckles
I like the third one better in the third
one
there's a 0.8
there's a point where uh
Indiana Jones bumps into Hitler and
Hitler gives him his autograph
Ed it's like sick so what do you think
about Elon taking over Twitter if I
think about that
sick
I saw this movie you guys see Hitler
Hitler was so awesome man
[Music]
what's your favorite thing about Hitler
every time you've asked this question
did you answer it I don't like it oh I
have to rule first but if you had to
pick dude
[Music]
it's funny I I just like do stuff and
then look at you guys
you're like the the council we have a
council we hold immense pal the Council
of Middle Earth I just want you to put
that wire underneath you so good I'll go
to the regular powers
yeah I loved it it was so good it was
epic and scale
[Music]
I thought it was pretty shitty but
nobody wants brick
the extended that's what I did after I
saw this episode it flows so well that
it doesn't feel like a 12 hour yeah
because it was all written out
beforehand
it was all shot as one giant movie and
they split it into three
oh really [ __ ] uh I watched them in
one hour increments Game of Thrones
they're just like picking up the pieces
as they go along
it's funny how much better movies are
when they follow the book but when they
get off track
it's like so much worse did you watch
the games the Lord of the Rings the
power this rings of power no that's
right it's so good numenor
the new minorians were so mighty and are
you being sarcastic it was awful it was
not good yeah
I loved it I thought it was great you
just relate to yourself I like the last
one yeah
we can put this cord below the table
[Laughter]
I'm not paying attention goddammit we're
talking about the Lord of the Rings
[Laughter]
you're such an idiot who is
dude
okay just chill out right all right okay
so what did you think about Elon Musk
taking over Twitter
I thought it was hilarious I think it's
it seems like he's fighting for free
speech I'm yeah I'm for Free Speech but
I'm not before what he's doing success
that's what I exactly what I expect or
did you I watched a video on him today
what he wants to do with it he had this
idea for like 20 years for the social
media when he started paper I'm sure he
[ __ ] said that I'm sure he said oh so
he's just like buying into something
yeah so he's just making it into what he
wanted to do back then and he wants
payment verification so then there can't
be Bots because if you have to get
botted well half of his Workforce left
so people who know how to work that
company are not there to help run the
company but there's many five bright
people that like working for him so
it'll be he'll be fine it's just like
he's just like an idea of what we think
someone like that should be but don't
think it works in practice I think
no are you are you still going for wheat
sheet for wheat anyway no no I'm okay
do you have shape yeah for a week wait
I think our generation people won't
remember presidents but they'll remember
Elon Musk
I think what he does he can't be good at
everything he can't be good at SpaceX
and Tesla and Twitter he's just
wondering solar panels it's so small the
only thing that we should do is
diversify that power and have everyone
have a hand in it they need one guy to
tell us what to do everyone needs to be
a part of it do you think he's good at
picking people to surround himself with
well it's really annoying is since yeah
I'll trade uh wait wait wait vacations
every time
does anyone want to break I'll take
wheat or Rock
or no how about two Rick for one of
those
we're all trying to do something right
now this is a hard time to trade
ruins the flow of conversations every
time well it's because we're playing
well it's good no one wants to talk
about Elon Musk that long
oh yeah unless he's a [ __ ] have you
met him no
damn that was a good card for that was a
good play for you man
I'm gonna play my uh night card because
I'm all right so what are what is one
positive one negative go ahead do that
no I mean you should see you spread them
what one positive one negative about
Elon Musk yeah it's fun it's funny it's
funny it's the positive yeah green and
brown but he's like [ __ ] up so bad
it's funny it's like what would happen
if your uncle took over a company oh no
I'm gonna make it like this so you know
I'll trade you back this for like one
negative is like it's like so
one person controls it huh one person
controls it yeah
which are just the economy
yes and he's just what he's really good
at is getting money getting investors
that's a skill he's not good at fiddling
around with cars and digging tunnels
he's good at [ __ ] getting people to
be like oh this guy's a genius let's
give him money it never even happened I
know it's like a shitty Subway
um
you couldn't talk more since Hans it's
incredible but does anybody want to
trade for a stone yes
what do you want okay I want um can you
give me a
I can only give you one thing
everyone has brick
all right
get your [ __ ] together any wood and a
brick
all right
and then you could trade the bricks in
thank you
I feel like we're online
this is the north versus the South I'm
sorry seven this is exactly why I didn't
do that if I had done that trade I would
[ __ ] myself so bad that would have been
awesome
[Music]
the unpredictable I mean I've lost
myself like Eric did
green and red green is got three points
so let me steal from Green
red has two points and he's cut off on
both of his rights
do you remember here cut off on
the phone do you remember when Riley got
cut off that one game yeah completely oh
my God but then he got stuck at nine
points and Derek dimple was about to win
that game or something yeah and we were
just like no let's leave
oops
Razzie was there wasn't any more points
that's called communism when you get
ahead we nip at your heels and bring you
down
I think we should have eight years of um
capitalism followed by four years of
socialism
thank you but we'll take it all
and there's a few people that are too
rich and need a restart three three
these threes are hot
I think it stinks so bad very
good you want two brick s
in a [ __ ] freak get a break in a sheep a
brick and a sheep breaking a sheep for
one war
brick and a sheet for one or how about a
wood
okay how about a brick
and a shape
[Laughter]
wow interesting
I'm gonna go ahead and build
this
evening
oh wow
foreign
so is it more than seven yeah
[Music]
perfect
so what do you think about the future of
the white race oh [ __ ]
however if I had done that deal earlier
you did that quietly I
was cars were really threes he kept
getting a hit you doing this guy
you should do that guy yeah I'm doing
that game didn't you roll a seven yeah I
had seven chords why don't you move your
[ __ ] robber
yeah
so what's going on what did you do chill
out what the hell did you just do
you roll the seven and you bought a city
I don't have any cards it's a steal from
one of those yes no he's winning I'm not
winning it's made he has more points
so you did you give up half your cards
no I had seven cards oh thank God and
then you just bought a city yep
what'd you get
uh I didn't need to show him you don't
do that well he would have known anyways
yeah I should have I didn't remember
what cards I had
one two three four one two three four
how many humans
about four hundred seven million sevens
uh seven
so I want to move it's the seven yeah I
still have seven hey guys leave it in
the chat where are you from
is the audio good what is he trying to
do what is Hans trying to do guys
so what do you think about the future of
the white race
I think they're going to be just fine
really you don't think they're going to
be a victim of a violent reprisal and a
Revenge no
what happened in South Africa I think
they'll they'll have to migrate but
they'll find somewhere else to take over
like we gave you the wars the war in the
battles we gave you the internet we gave
you who's gone with the ones
hey is it is it history
what do you mean by pronouns why are you
talking about things in symbols
again I'm allowed to block myself again
what did you roll a seven
and then give me why he's winning the
ridge has four points too I don't give a
[ __ ]
Bridge has four points I have three
points I don't care isn't that funny I
don't care it's weird
don't have that
those bigger Rings how uh how useful is
that sheet port for you
look at the best of the use that it's
having right keeping you guys from the
rest of the game there's gonna be like
one more three left and you better
utilize it
because your lucky Days Are Over bucko
bucko all you three
piece three T's
that you've ever had
what's that yeah have you ever had sex
not
more
are you good at it would you say you're
good at it you know seven hours seven 18
or 19 I was
seven again seven again I don't like
this but definitely not anymore not at
all anymore
well we all have our off days
just kidding you what is this three card
Monty
and just be like oh boom
[Music]
what what is that your invitation of how
you have sex no you know what you look
like right ten ten that's the first time
that's been rolled like a [ __ ] yes I
know oh hell yeah you still don't have
any cards this is so sad
we keep just trading cards
sixes haven't been rolled that much
anybody want or for a while Oh Daddy
what what
what huh what no no is it my turn yep
roll yourself oh dude an eight twelve oh
wow
likely
right so just for that stupid comment
I'm gonna play my night card now we
should have played it before your
tournament
no I could do whatever I want why is
there another one oh there's two dice
it's totally regretted
why is there no one
thinking your brain was like
because there's two dice I even counted
it out it's like there's five numbers
above seven and five below there's a
road
oh wow wow you almost have along this
road
no he does not
oh Santa funny
you
gotta break that
breaker of Rhodes wow what what what
what
okay
thank you
and uh in winter
about time
the solid turned it
he got lucky with the threes 12. oh
you're getting lucky with the twelves
yeah all those lucky sheep
some of us don't have access you putting
your house there is [ __ ] on so bad it
was hilarious dude it wasn't that funny
it was so funny
if he's doing fine
yeah go on sheep
me yeah wait no
about nothing
all right David six
that's what I'm talking about dude
I hope it Hans takes initiative to get
that night moved
the robber sorry it's tough
five
I think that's a five under there you
know
sadness
sometimes you just gotta roll the dice
and move your mask you do four oh yeah
give me some break
what are they watching It's Just Like
Music emotional noises it's like
softcore porn can you play an instrument
guitar
that's awesome proficient
oh well enough well enough
you can read music
a lot of musicians that I talk to don't
know how to read music
six
this is horrible I'm doing horrible guys
I'm saying
why did you build right there
maybe hey I need weight too yeah
who wants Rock we is definitely the
scariest resource
where did this game originate uh your
mom's [ __ ] yeah dude
that was awesome
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] he's doing it for a hang
damn that's a valuable ass hey dude it
is it really is man look there's 11 3
and 2 and [ __ ] five is the best thing
Hans of course put his [ __ ] there as he
gets first
he's really good at math and you know oh
thanks Gareth yeah no problem bud that
was an insolvable
dude Katana was invented in 2002.
really it's not very old
[Music]
you did a four trade for a tree
or a tree
oh what did you trade for enough
huh what did you trade for enough
or
you just didn't want to give it to
anyone well no one has no one had a tree
yeah I had brick I don't need it
dang it
or
what's your favorite thing about black
people
they're awesome they seem to be having a
good time
they're awesome really yeah like most of
them
longest road goes to Gareth oh wow look
at that
he's one away from artist Army wow for
that little [ __ ]
no I love black people I think they're
like historically marginalized and
they're uh amazingly talented and a lot
of different things
and I think that we should not bomb uh
Oklahoma City Tulsa
race riots
he's crazy so I found out about that
[ __ ] if you could go back in time would
you go back and help the Tulsa
maybe six
why
why wouldn't you
I mean yeah I mean even if you're like a
white supremacist or like maybe we
shouldn't kill black people it's like a
bad look so either way definitely not a
fan of this [ __ ] erase
what are you doing
uh I'm building a road
this way oh you son of a [ __ ]
and um
I'm trading these four or
you're never gonna guess what
what no what are you trying so far
wait five can you shoot
12 or 10 guys come on somebody roll it
in and get David you did it the first
time do it again for once Rock
brick yes no
sorry
cool action figure for this one I lost
it
who wants wood
yeah for what brick uh yeah I'll do that
somebody online buy uh Hans another cool
action
they were they're self-made before wait
somebody said to them Rock
I'm hot
foreign
what about sheep what about rock
I thought it was wheat
the most valuable resource
unobtaining weed
didn't Avatar like I loved that movie
but they had me up until they were like
I was like dude what the [ __ ] that's the
dumbest [ __ ] name ever for a precious
metal
also they [ __ ] totally stole that
whole plot from Dances with Wolves which
is a great [ __ ] movie I was all four
aliens with that plot or whatever
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you son of a
[ __ ]
who does that helps
[Music]
I was collecting your Jar of Hearts
[Music]
out there
I do have fun
I don't have anything it's Foghorn
Leghorn
Garrett do you like weed
what's your favorite strain of wean I
don't know any of them do you still have
that you're disgusting me you guys
as sweet huh
how are you doing dude
no I wait
that's the second time you've done that
I know
one two three four five
two three four five
this is a close game
it's too late I gotta own it
I wanted to do three for one with sheep
for a wood and it would take longest
road from careless oh wow we have a new
leader seven that's a big ass Road dude
that's a night from the road
got the car over there and Hans over
here ten oh yeah oh we should play a
drinking game while we do this yeah
tennis men have drinks tens yeah
you have nothing yeah we got a lot I
think let's let's do that anytime
somebody rolls what's been the least
rolled numbers it's just king's cup with
with uh numbers oh that would be cool as
[ __ ] yeah okay next
go get it wait no you know wait wait
wait wait wait foreign
go ahead go ahead go ahead it's your
turn that was absurd that was really
mean to me no that's fine that's fine
say whatever you have to say what takes
you a while to get your direction
oh I forgot about the robber we need to
get that thing out of there that's a
nice hit for me good for you you just
split the board
I mean about
[Music]
I forgot to do this two turns
to build this out but
you're gonna this is my land you're back
this is I appreciate it
completely correct I can't we can't
touch the longest road really we can't
touch it he could he could touch it we'd
have to I'd have to work so hard for it
right now dude let's roll you want more
let's go you want another wood
yes there is yes
[Music]
two bricks wait where's your you mean
liquor whatever bring whatever
I don't need that any combination
hello no thank you one two three four
we both were facing in opposite
directions though I didn't think
what are you draw in there
[Music]
Victory you just need a thing here and
it'll be a person kinda
why is there not a one
four four
let me go yell again
oh no
that's not oh this is how I found nice
is that was that all you brought is that
all you have I haven't seen it no it was
in the fridge you're coming into my
territory you're like a beer yeah
okay come in here with an empty box
seven I think is this it
I didn't know dude yeah like in the
fridge where people keep their legs
looks like Garrett only Gareth I sorry I
keep calling Gareth Garrett
you're grabbing two bricks for the four
rifle Foghorn Leghorn
did you have over seven cards no I did
not
you got rid of those last time yeah
foreign
on Sundays which you know
and um Sundays are awesome for images
what's going on it's nice to see Rogan
doing the show
s again who rolled what I rolled it
forward but we got you the two bricks oh
thank you all right
um does anyone want ore for
a wheat or a [ __ ] next to seven
leadership
yeah it looks like everything's chugging
along six everyone's having a good time
what do you think of the Austin comedy
scene at Hunts I think it's great I
think it's a good scene and we need an
alternative to La New York and we're
providing something new and
groundbreaking that's going to be
different
and it's going to be free and it's not
going to be
Holden to Old powers that it's like the
new yeah what's great about it in my
regard is that awesome has always been
Austin or Austin has always been a
couple of Music City
growing up I mean this shit's awesome
everybody like in concert here I've seen
[ __ ] everybody
and uh now you're it's your turn
listen don't talk to him
oh yeah it's a whole new Austin now I'm
excited because it's true it's still not
done because Rogan's Club is going to
show up sometime
that'll add something to it for
awesome
do you think that overall like we should
be giving more money to poor people
in what sense
welfare programs affordable housing
Health Care
yeah food stamps
absolutely yeah and for all of that I
think taking care of people we can send
billions of dollars to
nine War efforts but then why is that so
unpopular why is like people why is that
not a bigger thing because people think
they're lazy and they don't want to give
them money but they'll give money to a
bank
that lost its money during the bailout
that would be cool but who knows it
definitely I do think it's some sort of
like primitive thing of like looking at
it as like a weakness
without especially if you can't
understand the person's circumstances in
which they are coming from the where
they actually need the food stamps in
healthcare
like if you haven't experienced it
yourself and absolutely you'd be like I
always worked for what I got yeah I mean
it's
it's just
it's not even individual people's fault
it's like I'm a threesome system God
damn it it doesn't matter what we think
it's just like that's the system
we'll build two more rows
we're even about to build these roads at
huh ready
I'm getting that rug
s
every four that comes I get closer every
four year old
does anyone want wood
for
wheat or sheep
oh
what
weiner sheep as sheep
for what what
six
we have wood
or six
how many words do you have sir David
11.
is that true
it's true
okay so what do you think about Kanye
the Trudy's back on Twitter
was he kicked off was he kicked off
Twitter
yeah not really or he deactivated it and
came back huh
I'm not up on the news folks
I'm living my life
do you think people should be more
informed someone from Portugal is
watching
what city in Portugal oh he's super cool
guy
Portugal in the house
what's Portugal known for
uh
um
like they had a lot of explorers
the Portuguese
Portugues 10.
guys this this is not going well for me
I started off hot oh wait tin's the one
where we're supposed to drink so they're
good buddy yeah
that was the least uh drawn number early
what would you want to go with because
that's a higher probability it's a three
no you got to pick odds or evens
I'm super down for that let's go first
even so you guys got odds
are gonna be the evens are much more
higher
I drink every turn
oh damn it Hans has got the triangle
pattern going on with [ __ ] you guys
it's a little X it's a y Wing from that
it's got a little bit if I get into the
shooters it's not good it looks like uh
those that old video game
it's not good
it's not good
what is he doing
wait so are we drinking or not I'm gonna
drink yeah
seven
they're odd we're even
oh
same time we roll an even number than we
have to right anytime even numbers
rolled oh we have to do three four see
I'll have to is there a shot
I don't know what if do you do it dude
I haven't drank in a long time why are
you wearing that beanie yeah what are
you trying to hide what's your name
what's your in here what do you do
are you trying to hide
the fact that you're around the presence
of drugs and alcohol no alcohol is fine
I'm not ready
on the account
Fatboy
I don't know where this [ __ ] comes
from it's like
you're done yeah
probably stealing from me
four
that's even yeah
um I try to wait for wood here's the
thing
um
the creek in the cave is taking us two
for what wait oh the uh
shoes are around
are you gonna be here for Christmas Hans
probably I'm flying in from Tacoma
Washington hopefully I will have a show
it's gonna be a Christmas show that
would be great
oh Shalom that's what it was five
whoever
Fox Media five five
I thought I was almost like the fight
there's that where I get shaped and then
what would I get a shooting
yet
sit down with that
yeah
I'm stacked up on that baby
11.
so I'll trade you in ore for a wood is
anybody no one
all right never mind my turn
did you know this is for a hundred
dollars yeah no it's actually 400.
10.
foreign
want sheep or wood or wheat or Rock I
want more than wheat
what do you need I need to wait oh you
need me
I buy myself a city
nobody four five four six
damn force and five is just getting two
now we have to put it on
three
does nobody have
wood
now what do you want for it don't trade
with them wait you want wheat
look how many cards he has seven points
I'm not I'm at four no him oh don't
trade with him oh you're talking to me
no daddy says dude
correct he says no why
yay
one two three four sure you wanna do it
wait how do you feel about the games
you're gonna let him decide this for you
I think they're fine they're great
they're great people they're not trying
to get our children up to suck their
dicks if you don't want to do it no I
don't want to do it three ores for a
wood
oh my God what a decadent man
what wait I'll do that [ __ ] too late am
I too late is that a point you gotta
catch him
Bros
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven you need two more roads
you better do uh wait I'll do it stop
Ridge no did you do that he has eight
points you idiot what are you doing are
you not like playing well you think he's
gonna win this round yes he's in eight
points if not this round the next round
12. congratulations Ridge
did he win you can't call that road
Ridge Ridge Road
Hershberger Lane
I was scared you're gonna win for a
second
I would have been felt bad then
11. oh well I didn't even need [ __ ] dude
I'm not gonna say anything I'm drinking
just like I don't care if it's evens or
dogs I'm bigger than that hell yeah
that's what this is the best is the uh
emptiness of meaning behind your
gestures
what the less meaning there is behind
what you do the cooler you are
Jesus Christ
bridge is up to
so he's at six
cheers son
good job Bridge
chugging along
okay
he loves that spot
come on Gareth build the road
eight he's cut off he can only build one
more level I see I see so I'm gonna
build two roads
you can't vote around a settlement I
thought you could go like it I thought
you could build around the settlement I
didn't mean to bring it up
what did you say I think you can build
around the settlement one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve one two three four
ten eleven right what's the difference
we're tied uh Ty you need one more you
need one more
um what do you need but if you guys give
it to him though you're just giving them
the win because he gets nights with one
more night
yeah he only has four settlements you
have four settlements and it's like
literally the best numbers on the board
so you guys no he has tens and fours he
just picked up those two points
nope nope nope I did not see anybody
want to trade a sheep for a brick
nope no one has brick
three [ __ ] you
God damn it
were you at eight [ __ ]
he might but you have to assume he's in
line with that point
[Music]
God
for right now no you can't get to it so
you can't build the rest I don't know
you only have one rope left
you only have one road left one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen so
you're wrong [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh no
oh no
what the night like this I'm still from
Ridge one two three
four five three seven eight nine ten one
twelve thirteen
three brick for a sheep
wheat
then the brick
and I'll add my turn that son of a [ __ ]
nine he can't go under nine either
we can't knock him down at all
road to stop him
shut up yeah if they work together to
let him pass I could have I was thinking
about cutting you off earlier
but I didn't I just built a giant Road
to Nowhere
[Laughter]
dude oh God damn it what am I doing oh
at least you built four settlements on
the way
uh could you go
tense
do I have another settlement even yeah
the two and the three
you're rocking that too dude that's
who's
Ridge
if you hit that too
six good for the Earth
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can't build any more settlements right
so he can't we don't he can't let him
get a city
what was this roll to three
I want to play the night card oh a six
oh no
oh no we just got three points is seven
couldn't care
and I'm going to move I have six points
where's David's number we've got to get
you got to get one he's red one two
three four five six he just got three so
he has three three
oh my goodness he has it
you have it not anymore
oh he's gonna take one
because you got the perfect roll
two times the three
is three yeah are you done six I'm done
oh my goodness you got the perfect roll
dude
but you just we'll see how that night
because they're gonna keep stuff oh
there we go yeah I knew I should have
done it this should have been nice
all right
Oh I thought it was a [ __ ] thing
ah [ __ ]
Ah that's gonna cut you off
but then Gareth would be sitting pretty
right now
Garrett one two three four five six
seven right now we're all at seven Hans
is losing let's see if it's something
keep on the comments section damn it
when you [ __ ] idiot
you're right Brad
that's awesome goodness gracious
let's figure this out let's see what
what rage is made of Ridge could come
back right now
eight
that was the same one as last time
the sheet ports
damn it no wait no no no we need three
you need three ore boom boom boom Oh you
have two oh you have that [ __ ] break
board you son of a [ __ ]
who cares you suck
look how happy he is I did like that
Hans got last place I like that that was
good that was good you could have got
with the road by one point when you get
last place it's like you got three
points the whole game yeah man I don't
know what's going on
[Laughter]
in the morning and I'm like why am I
here all right boys we gotta head out
India yeah I got work in the morning oh
me too what time is it 11 30.
well I mean it was good hey yeah this is
a fun one
I mean yeah
if you have one extra person we can
continue this if David you yeah let's
stick it out for one more let's take it
out if we can get one other person
let's see what that the [ __ ] Patrick
of course
jamisha can come
oh she did it sends a text at 10.
well what do you want to do
I mean if somebody else's down to come
over and let him play
oh look at that what are you doing you
idiot all right guys I'll see ya see you
yep
you should come play over at Holland's
man
uh it's over in our neck of the woods
it's off 33rd Street
yeah it's really close to the house
oh my God stop telling people what
street I live on
oh
I said it was really close to my place
at our place shut up anyway I'll see it
yeah yeah also I'll shoot you the the
sounds good Ben all right you'll see in
a minute
so what do you guys think about the uh
the midterms
yeah
there's a lot of balance right now I
really hope Trump doesn't get reelected
obviously
you think so
I hate to say it but I think that's
probably gonna happen I don't think so
I mean I really hope not
don't worry it's recording
is this still online are we still live
right now yeah
that's beautiful
last place what an idiot
I only got one point more than me
you got seven points
good job dude
come on so uh what else have y'all been
up to David how have you been are you
going anywhere for the holidays you take
it off no stand here you're staying here
testing one two three hey guys I'm
outside here this is Rich
I just walked away with hans's mic
um I wonder if this is still connected
there's no way for them to tell oh yeah
go ahead knock the walking back up to
him right now
to uh the Colin o'mares place is having
oh my God
in the Stream right even yourself
that's great
so then I'm going to Colin O'Mara's
place he's having a bunch of people over
other comments and stuff and then we're
gonna I'm gonna go to uh
the creek after that that's the plan
so what do you think about Biden
Jesus Christ what I do wish you would uh
send me that are or uh oh you would go
to Thanksgiving again to ask these
questions to my family because they it
was great it was the best Thanksgiving
ever last year when you did that dude
thanks man yeah it was [ __ ] hilarious
thanks dude never be upped
oh [ __ ] you Hans
so have you seen the uh Ukraine footage
yeah war footage yeah they're like
dropping grenades on them with drugs
yeah it's sick it's like so weird
because it's like it seems like they
survive
I don't think it kills them right away
the uh oh no
do you watch the video of the guy
talking about it the Russian guy that
like threw off the grenades like he got
hit with grenades and then he like dude
they're trying to kill him again because
he'd die he kept hitting him up and
throwing them away it's for like an hour
or two they just kept throwing grenades
at him and he's just like oh [ __ ] it's
like someone dropping fireworks on you
they're much worse than that yeah it's
much worse yeah
about a hundred times worse I mean [ __ ]
like that really
yeah and causing it elsewhere
I'd rather that than yeah we could have
neither we could have the best of both
worlds because we could there's no
denying that but if you could if you if
this is a direct result of us pressuring
Russia and trying to take as much from
them as possible and not giving them a
fair shot
and they they have no choice
they have no other uh besides the
weather like six minutes
okay
uh does he live up here too I don't know
that who else lives up here I think
Ridge says he lives up here
I don't know that they lived all over
the place
yeah where do you think the trajectory
is because I think when people first
moved to Austin they moved to East
Austin like South
um South and South Congress East awesome
like [ __ ] Riverside
a lot of people live in Riverside price
too high now for what it is yeah no it
didn't be on her side and I will say
cleaning the homes was like zombie so I
lived there they put them a lot of them
in hotels
I almost lived in that same building
with dude it was awful oh it was
horrendous it's good to live on the same
side of the river as downtown because
having to cross the river is uh it's a
pain in the ass sometimes
and plus we're because you got to think
about Cap City too yeah think about
being North
a lot of shows in there
and I think it's just coming from the
south I mean I go to Dallas more than I
go to San Antonio
and I know those are both far but it's
like it's it's nice to not have that 30
minute headache I'm having to get
through [ __ ] downtown
uh by [ __ ] Aunt used to say the
secret to having this and Austin is
avoiding I-35 yes you shouldn't have a
giant Highway running through the middle
of your city well did you know that the
the stretch of I-35 from Riverside to
here or to around like a certain area is
very specific yeah with my stats is like
General vagueness anyway
um
who the [ __ ] saying [ __ ]
[ __ ] you man
anyway uh
it's the most deadly strip of Highways
every city says that it's in so many
different polls and different whatevers
it's just that stretch every city in
America is dog [ __ ] with infrastructure
and it kills a lot of pedestrians and
you're not supposed to be a human being
in American cities
the uh the Mopac pour off
right where uh Cesar Chavez is
right it's where it splits where you
could either go to the right and go to
Caesar oh my God
for my life the stupidest [ __ ] noise
why would you go from four lanes to two
and have it mirror there are spaces in
Houston where you're you think you're in
Spain just traffic rules no longer exist
for like a block radius and you're like
what the [ __ ] just happened like a wire
takeoff died huh yeah it's for takeoff
died
in Houston yeah no so I was there for
the World Series because drunk oh my God
and we we ended up
um like with me and my friend were like
trying to get to the stadium at one
point and the stadium traffic wasn't bad
the problem was is that some of the
lights weren't working and what I mean
by not working was the traffic lights
just weren't home and so they were and
this was at like a highway intersection
like from the KD freeway or like uh I-10
or some [ __ ] like
and uh it was just like a mile and it
was just Bumper to Bumper stopped
traffic for like 20 minutes and he said
he finally got to the light and uh yeah
it was Madness yeah you know what [ __ ]
you guys it was a lot of traffic
this is no way
sorry I was watching
yeah
Randomness and you're ruining it with
your white man hands no I want [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] man dude this is the
way the numbers are this is the way the
tiles fell this is a map my [ __ ]
idiot friend Grant would build dude he'd
just be like this looks good
it's your subjective opinion of what
looks good does not make a good Katan
map you know what there needs to be
Randomness and beauty and
collisions and everything
let's start with this this is how life
is
sometimes life be that way wow
this map is crazy it's random you just
saw how the sausage is made yeah
it's just a wild one
all the resources are grouped together
the wheat's all right here the wood is
mostly here we got one wood right there
or very small numbers on sheep or is
weak sheep is weak too
quick is strong
yeah it's gonna be a long [ __ ] you man
just [ __ ] road building everyone's
gonna be building roads
it was gonna be fighting for territory
this is a dog fight this is fun and we
know they always play yeah
that's what you sound like right now
this is a tough map
it's fine I feel like someone will run
with it though we're gonna figure it out
Patrick the party
tell them to share a location
75
[Music]
yeah I-75 though man that goes to the
whole country
so it's kind of like that that's been
there we need trains trains don't have
so many uh
you know like when you're traveling to
[ __ ] Dallas you don't need to be able
to go all the way around well you don't
need that much freedom
you just need to track just [ __ ] go
right there there's a straight line
[ __ ] Zoom it's the most efficient to
have everyone on this giant Highway with
their wheels and they can swerve all
over the highway that's not nobody wants
to do that that's not an important
freedom we need we need to go fast in
One Direction that's all anyone cares
about
jetpack
we don't get jealous
yeah that'd be sick right
Could Happen what do you think about
free speech on Twitter do you think like
you should be able to say whatever you
want or do you think that there should
be something you should be able to say
whichever you want it should be like
that's that's not free speech though
that's falls under there's laws
protecting those kids right yeah but
what about gay violence no that actually
falling down yeah okay yeah then what
about
stochastic terrorism
I don't know what that is like if you
just go out on Twitter and say every day
gays suck kill them gay suck kill all
right that's technically well then gay
sucks they're the worst okay suck they
don't deserve to be drinking it just
raises the virus and it kills people
that's still
like how much of it do you allow because
the other one is just curse words and
then that one is just like days are the
worst I don't like gays and I don't like
living with them and then I just raises
the temperature and then someone
somewhere kills if you put it out to
enough people so if you know a guy
that's doing that and you're like hey
let's start for terrorism
I mean there's always everyone like
everyone is like free everyone is like
Free Speech but then like then you have
to run Twitter and then they're like
what about rohingya minorities getting
murdered on Facebook or like
you know
um
we should have a Minority Report
um like I mean if they're so in our
pockets they should pedophilia terrorism
Isis
it's probably the easiest thing to track
nowadays
I think people still get caught for it
they're still out there they get caught
because they're they can crack down on
that I think so you think that there
should we should only follow the laws
when it comes to you know what I'm
saying is I think it's harder to catch
into running a private company it's
harder to catch it I like white
supremacy than it is a child porn right
because there's actual evidence with the
child performing the domestic terrorist
could be someone that just like snaps or
is planning something in their head it's
so hard to like so do you think that you
should just let anyone say anything on
Twitter no but you should definitely
like pay attention to them
on Twitter just saying stuff that falls
in line with the past like like if
someone isn't domestic terrorist look
into their like their wording and how
they dialogue things and then profile
them yeah I mean that's good but that's
not the question the question is Twitter
like would you
Twitter would you would you have free
speech on Twitter or would you like
police it a little bit well you police
it from behind the scenes
but you let people speak their mind
because then you can keep better items
though so would you ban Andrew Tate I
don't know much about him so like I
don't know well just their idea of him
like a guy a guy that says misogynistic
things do you think that he should be
wouldn't it always be your opinion of
things
but isn't there an objective truth like
in terms of slavery that was once up in
the air like
yeah like if you're like generally
slavery is a bad thing and we should
like not be for that and it's like oh
that's just your opinion man
like should we like try and be like hey
we know the right answers now and it's
not with these people that we're
supporting slavery and segregation and
homophobia and transphobia and did you
see yeah today was like I'm not gonna
let you
lose on Twitter
because my 10 month old
yeah so that's his like personal bias
that's your personal thing yeah you
can't make fun of dead kids now yeah
right yeah which is like
I get that but yeah that is true so you
bought Twitter to do that and his
version of playing with censorship is
like so much less sophisticated it's
just a personal experience yeah it's not
even like rooted in like
but if you are if you run a company like
Twitter and you happen to hate
uh white supremacy
would you would you think it's your
responsibility to police white supremacy
or no
have you ever watched those uh
soft white underbelly videos on YouTube
yeah where they interview like Clans
members and like klansmen and [ __ ]
and like that's right for the most part
they kind of seem just dumb yeah like
ignorant does kind of mean dollars
they are definitely dumb like there's
like there's a guy like there's the like
well I just don't think that I just
don't think people are like smart enough
to stay safe decipher information on
their own I think people are busy
it's not like an objective thing it's
not like we get all the information and
then it's not like we get all the
information and we make an objective
well it's not like we get an objective
measure of like what the [ __ ] is going
on it's just like we're all hurried and
busy and I think like I don't know I
don't think it's good to let everyone
like fall into Flat Earth would you
censor Flat Earth
eight no
there's no one because it doesn't hurt
it doesn't hurt anyone to let those
people be stupid
yeah it does you don't think Flat Earth
hurts people no
like families or like people that are
obsessed my high school girlfriend got
in a fight about it because she thought
it was like a joke it's a bad way to
think it leads to other things at least
it wasn't yeah
it's a bad thought it's like it gets in
your head and you like [ __ ] what is that
like 20 seconds
I like it was kind of like it was kind
of like an internet joke and my
girlfriend isn't my friend yeah it's
your turn no it's my turn oh [ __ ] my bad
dude I'm an idiot nothing's new there
yeah me and my girlfriend at the time
like she brought it up to me like hey
what are you think and I was like well
this is and I got like kind of mad
because I was like well this is stupid
and then she got like mad at me she was
like it's a joke and I was like oh okay
so there you go it caused the fight
between me and my girlfriend
so what more could it do what couldn't
it do dude what what couldn't the Flat
Earth conspiracy do dude what what an
idiot first off let me tell your
girlfriend who I was cheating on to
fight
what an idiot though she couldn't even
tell you're cheating I mean what about
what about not censoring Flat Earth but
just not putting it on the featured page
like oh it's getting a lot of views but
um
you know they edit the feature page very
heavily it's not accurate or else it
looks like okay look at YouTube
yeah YouTube does that hardcore I mean
it's also like paid sponsorships like
paid promotional type [ __ ] yeah
I just think that I think speech is a
delicate beautiful flower and if you
just have people in there just shouting
the n-word and stuff it brings down the
community
and uh like
at some point you don't have to listen
to people that are obviously wrong
yeah no I completely agree with you dude
it makes a ton of sense man but I don't
I think it's fun to have like the
free-for-all where everyone's fighting
and arguing and stuff and I think like
generally like you don't want to overdo
it but I think it's easy to not overdo I
think the lines are pretty clear
definitely absolutely but you know what
I've liked about being here and also at
these open minds is there is still a lot
of people just saying you know
crazy [ __ ] out there things you aren't
supposed to say well that's [ __ ]
sweet dude like you know it sounds like
a swiggy
I think it's fine uh
yeah I think like you should be able to
say that
um but yeah like
there's a clear boundary you know who's
[ __ ] saying [ __ ] that's hateful and
who isn't right like you know when
somebody's being a hateful cockhead you
know when uh Chris is well I think it's
having a good time just saying you know
say what you have to say but
I don't know I just think it's uh
it's
like
I don't know like ideas are precious and
whose [ __ ] turn is it just got to me
the ideas Market is very polluted
and it's a big word waking up
so that's your second settlement yeah
[ __ ] you Patrick why'd you do that dude
you all are good to go again
you you you're a [ __ ] you know what
you just did to me you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
we all went around you
yeah it's the best spot clearly
yeah you got a good spot I think it
should be determined democratically
what
what uh speech is
uh like
what sort of uh
risk like uh whoa dude you're choking on
your own words it's happening right now
I'm thinking have you ever heard of it
it sounded like a [ __ ]
well I don't know
you look
at that thanks man that's part of my
protocol
my regimen oh good job dude look at you
I've gotten the fatter since the last
time me too dude I'm so fat now man it's
awesome I've gotten I've put on like 40
pounds it's like unfortunately I'm still
gonna do my weight loss joke
I'm gonna do it I don't care dude I
don't care if it's gone the opposite
direction that joke is good it's not
good if anything people thought I was oh
it's a good joke it's a solid joke
I have a good weight loss joke [ __ ] you
man and [ __ ] you why did you put your
[ __ ] there dude there's literally no
reason to put that [ __ ] down why am I
gonna play for you
why did you put that if you put yourself
on that [ __ ] 11 4 8 week you might
get a sick [ __ ] game of just hoarding
wheat and then you can trade
because everyone you'll be you're a
[ __ ] Patrick I can't believe you
[ __ ] me like that why'd you [ __ ] me
there's no reason for you to do that
you [ __ ] me anyway I kept decide I'm
playing this side of the board you
[ __ ] me
I'm gonna [ __ ] you if anything I
separated my things a lot oh [ __ ] you
you're a son of a [ __ ] dude
is your place alone yeah it's a [ __ ]
nice place so you haven't
it's a nice but what have you seen it
isn't that crazy is anybody here seen
any good movies recently
nobody we were watching the making of
nope before you guys got here the making
of them I didn't even watch nope it's
not bad I heard it was I
so what do you think about uh
like
Trump huh
yeah he's a funny guy if anything he can
say he's funny what do you think about
Kanye which is censor Kanye well I saw
he's gonna get killed dude
back to Twitter like the same day and
then Kanye tweeted Shalom which was
hilarious and I feel back on Twitter too
yeah Trump and Connie got back on
Twitter at the same time like their
accounts both got like thrown back on
again at the same day
tweeted Shalom oh my God I feel like
Trump was like you need to repeat
something but then Trump saw that Kanye
tweeted Shalom and he was like that's
hilarious how do I how do I up that I
can't I can't do anything funnier than
that that's so funny dude
isn't it funny that his last post is
from January 8th 2021. I'm not gonna be
at the what happened around that time
pick up your second settlement
I know he doesn't even know it's back
yet he's just
say wait I got
it what do you think of trump somebody
on a two I think uh you can't just do
what feels good all the time oh horns is
okay sometimes you gotta do things you
don't want to do and Trump makes you
feel good all the time but that's not
necessarily what you need to do no he's
not a good leader all right
what do you think about
having a panel of leaders instead of one
president yeah or just voting on
everything a panel of like 40 people
just vote on everything
no government
no government dude no laws we are the
government uh
I rolled a nine
no
a four excuse me I wrote
it and then I got a development card
the development card
what is the development card that's not
what they're called what are you called
11.
come on eight
let's come on eight five ten four
any of those numbers
that's what I really need
a funky you [ __ ] dude
yeah piece of [ __ ]
why you gotta do that dude why did you
have to put I'm playing the game [ __ ]
come on man like Ripley it doesn't
there's no need for it can we see that
do you think that uh the
financial crisis
was the result of our greed and
selfishness
what's still happening
exactly we haven't learned our lesson no
I mean the economy's kind of class
everything that happened in uh the wolf
or in uh The Big Short like it's
continuing to this day all of that stuff
still going on
I just feel like
a lot of people are just
scared and white
uh yeah for sure absolutely that's what
country music is it's a bunch of scary
white people that are afraid shut up
I mean do you think that uh
the
uh
the whole thing you're the same the
whole car dependent infrastructure is
good I'm returned yeah that's fun I
watched a video about a guy that came
here from uh Germany for F1 seven and he
uh ended up like being from a place
right where it was a completely car
dependent City but he thought he was
blown away coming to Austin he's like I
had to park
15 minutes away from the grocery store
to get to the grocery store from where I
was at Drive park my car like he was
like well he was like this is [ __ ]
crazy because in Germany you just rode a
bike like down the store or down the way
and got all over [ __ ] and went home
he's like I gotta drive 15 minutes to
HEB go through sit through traffic and
[ __ ] come back like it's completely
different but uh I really don't like the
Austin biking Community they're a bunch
of [ __ ] they can all burn in hell my
whole life they've just been [ __ ]
so that's a fun fact for you well
infrastructure has always sucked and
we've always been like we gotta add
another Lane to everything and then that
[ __ ] Lane we added was for bikers for
some reason no I've always thought
bikers that was the whole thing it makes
me so mad
so let's hear such [ __ ]
outside
no yeah there's no reason why they're
not allowed I always give them a ton of
space and then always in Austin there's
a guy that's just like [ __ ] you you're
too close so I'm literally in another
[ __ ] Lane I'm like you're just a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] actually just hit
you
[ __ ] you
but anyway can you think of any more
boring topics to talk about other than
infrastructure you [ __ ] Patrick do
you think that uh
what'd you get
seven again
from Hans
he's got a bunch
David won last time
[ __ ] you get it from him you know that's
great I don't have any breaks
I'm not giving you anything dude
son of a [ __ ] so what do you think
about the metoo movement
oh boy come on Hans you know that's not
the question to ask me
full questions oh God
[Laughter]
everyone's made mistakes
uh no you're fine everybody has those
days
everybody knows what what I'm talking
about
well I just think that women are just
shitty people sometimes quite sure
I mean you know people uh
people uh people give too much to the uh
like internet
uh internet accusation type things
obviously
um
like some some girl being like okay
like uh I'm into like wrestling which is
lame like
before read it but uh you mean I know of
a story where a girl
um used to date this wrestler
and then he's like famous now like he's
a millionaire now but when they were
dating he was like a struggling guy he's
a struggling wrestler yeah
recently and was like
you know at the time he would like at
the time of our relationship he would
like ask me to have sex
and I wouldn't want to but I would say
yes anyway just to make him happy and
what I know now is that's right and it's
like well that's not right that's not
Rave you were yeah they think every
unpleasant interaction in the general Ms
like misanthropy they have is because of
men but I was like they gotta like fix
her [ __ ] but obviously like men are way
worse it does happen obviously men are
horrible people compared to women
no one wants it okay oh we yeah no I'm
good
nine I think the metoo movement could
have been much stronger for sure well
women are hysterical and they let their
feelings get in the way and ruin their
own
um
I think men take advantage of like metoo
movement type stuff where they're like
oh yeah you guys are getting a little
bit of a like momentum I can like cash
in on this and use it for something that
I want you know yeah like the me too
movement was was capitalized what the
hell was that it is six
roll it properly next time man Jesus
Christ
what the [ __ ] did I do wrong man you
just do you just you uncapped dribbled
it up
a brick okay I wasn't sure if you picked
up too
man
well you can go now whatever
eight
give me some hay
and
um
who wants to trade a wood for a brick
wood for a brick what's another topic
you have huh
Patrick
what is your favorite
what do you like about
you have a brick dude
what do you think about America's
coveted response
too much to have a calm down you know
hey we lost the most people in the world
when I'm driving and I think about like
the ventilator situation and how they
killed like 200 000 people I like
[ __ ] lose my mind well what do you
what would you do we have a friend one
of our comic friends
six
I won't say who outside science works
you gotta try things and you fail
sometimes I mean come on I mean what
would you do insulator situation what
happened with the ventilators they
didn't work Hans you gave me oh they
made the lung situation worse they made
your lungs dependent on it and then when
you take them off people die immediately
honestly I don't know but if they needed
a ventilator they were probably gonna
die soon anyways
are you going to post this video to
YouTube yeah it's being posted
why not won't they just flag it
immediately and take it down I hope so
I mean I just feel like we were very
impatient and that's fine we don't have
to live if you don't want to
yeah I mean that is true I was in uh I
was in New York during like when the
covet was first breaking out like across
Seas breaking out and I come I remember
one at the basement in the creek in the
cave this comic went up and he was like
uh
he was like y'all think we're gonna get
covered and everybody in the room was
like no [ __ ] that bunch of [ __ ]
nothing that means nothing and then like
three weeks later we were all foreign
you can't be like afraid or a little
spread and so when you're in a social
situation you got to be calm right
yeah true that's why I like when Comics
I mean just from five just from that
interaction when uh when people [ __ ] you
go up on stage now and they're like you
think we're all gonna get monkey pox I'm
like hey I'm staying out of this one not
anymore never know I learned
I mean it's a humility
is something to do
I mean we're not doing anything
important as a society anyways
we're not even good at staying alive and
treading water
so it's like why are we breaking our
necks and killing people to fund this
economy that's like this purpose isn't
even to Keep Us Alive
oh that's a great question but who
[ __ ] knows dude [ __ ] knows Hans
what does it all really matter in the
long run
does it matter we're all gonna die
think about it it was good I think it
was good to be like what is this all for
why am I doing this and people like
started quitting their job and stuff
seven well I worked from home at the
time and I hadn't started comedy so
admit nothing to me
good to know
uh
[ __ ] you
Patrick
what do you think about the uh state of
the world
right now
you know we're on the brink of chaos but
it's cool I'm down it's all right what
are you gonna do about it not a big
celebrity Devil in a while cheating
really well it wasn't the the guy from
the the green the cool Power Ranger
the Green Power Ranger that's a lazy Dev
that's a lousy they kill himself lousy
they kill himself
no no no no Power Rangers that's a
flasted depth yeah yeah he's one step
above a storm
no Power Rangers colorful Stormtroopers
Power Rangers are in the [ __ ] dude
Falcon Zordon bulk is Zordon Miami
did you know about Zordon dude no Zordon
bro
that intro is ridiculous it's true
I'll do a Wii and a sheet for two bricks
I need the wood I'll do an or
and a sheep
or and a sheep for two brick
two for two I'm gonna call Colin right
now but otherwise I don't just got to
start dethawing the turkey what do you
think about the uh
do you think that we should ban
entertain or no
or release Andrew Tate
Colin Colin do you think well what was
your question
okay I don't know but do you think a guy
that's just massage
I catch myself like when I'm just
naturally have like I just have natural
misogynist I think men just naturally
have misogynistic thoughts I catch
myself and I'm very much a level and I'm
very much like Ah that's kind of crazy
I'm not gonna be super mean yeah so we
need to have that as a society
as a society I watched one clip of
Andrew Taylor recently and he was just
talking to a guy who like uh yeah I'm
all set
yeah all right do not like this
conversation
well why don't you participate instead
of this
well what do you think about
Alex Jones
oh Alex Jones what a guy he's from here
who did the parents of the dead children
they tend to do that those
parents and dead children they got a
little emotional well they have more
time on there I used to love Alex Jones
and think he was amazing and funny and
then that all happened it was like I
still think is it funny but gosh darn
when you hear the parents be like
I was getting [ __ ] harassed after
your kid gets shot to death and you're
being harassed by all these mental yeah
if you're wrong that's such a costly
error
yes
if you're wrong then yeah that's like
yeah you can't go do a pedophile joke
before you can't do a pedophile joke
without a good punch line that's right
and turns out it seems like it was
probably wrong about that one they
probably weren't actors
foreign
do you have the longest road card yeah
all right I don't have the card but I
have a sweet
okay
thank you sir
did you just build a patch right now
three four
so what do you think about Gareth do you
think that maybe he's six to vocal
he used to like think before he speaks a
little bit more
you know he did uh what's this [ __ ]
Foghorn Leghorn yeah he went up on stage
last night and did a Foghorn Leghorn
that's great that's a reference from the
1930s
I was also gonna do my baby weathers
impression
beanie weathers leads the NFL still to
this day I mean in yards per carry
characters are not really that popular
anymore but if you think you're better
than Jim Carrey than and Robin Williams
then I'd say go ahead and try
Impressions he did uh he did a they did
a Foghorn Leghorn version let's type
it's not even a good impression though
yeah but it's like once you get too much
confidence in that it turns cringe oh no
you gotta have humility and I've got a
joke but then it's like why are you
doing it over and over again unless yeah
it's good I'll give you
a week yeah all this time especially
your own
wheat and one wood for one sheep one
wheat
done where so I mean I don't know dude
I've gotten I've got like 10 minutes and
I got good jokes for so I can do other
[ __ ] but I like to go out there and just
do stupid [ __ ]
I love stupid [ __ ] stupid shit's fun I
like to have fun what does it matter if
it's seven of us at an open mic at the
creek in the game what the [ __ ] is it
I'm gonna do something great stuff man
still and doing [ __ ] I think if you're
having fun and you're good at having fun
that's comedy all right
thank you
no tonight I uh I did Baker Street and
uh they because of the World Cup they
hung a Russian flag like in the middle
of a bar oh what a bunch of things yeah
who's in The World's Cup they should
take it out yeah the Russian flag was up
there yeah so I walked up and I was like
everyone else staring at that Russian
flag it's crazy around the world a bunch
of multitaskers of those [ __ ] folks
three but then I said
dude what's going on man
[Laughter]
are we screaming
the first one yeah was that real did we
actually [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] is that real dude I thought
Richard was [ __ ] around man were you
playing money playing content for money
yeah no dude we were you are right now
I'm down to do it now is that true I
mean what are you looking at meow
malevolent for you piece of [ __ ] well I
agree with Patrick like you should be
what were you talking about
all right I forgot what we were talking
about before but it made me bring up
Russia oh Russia yeah you're just
telling a joke that went well Russia
tonight yeah yeah good job man you
killed it supposedly what were you
talking about before that yeah Russia
Ukraine
who's trying to guess it's my turn
oh Russia was in the World Cup yeah but
why did I bring that up
I forget we were talking about uh
all gay dicks yeah dude looking day
draining it out Cox over there dude
[ __ ] big old idiot David is there a
chat
this is a moment to go to the chat and
say what the [ __ ] were we doing Alex
Jones
Russia you said something about comedy
comedy
we should be fearless and cool we should
be so fearless and cool and [ __ ]
awesome are you done Kara yeah man [ __ ]
yeah that's the dice yeah I mean I think
like overall comedy is like great
we gotta respect all mediums yeah give
me that sheep
you having fun out on the road
oh yeah
do you have any lady friends
are you lonely friends
[ __ ] you dude
exactly
I told you not to easily
Brian lives here yeah you lied
if you leave her alone all right did I
he said yes this is my phone Hans does
that a lot you have to watch her he's
Shifty
so do you think that we should be able
to legalize marijuana in the South and
why haven't we done it yet and is it I
can tell you why has to keep some things
keep something like what no it's just
Texas at this point this is what I was
thinking about you know people talking
about cancer culture nowadays like the
right talks about cancer culture and how
[ __ ] Liberals are like liberal like
Fox News is doing like a documentary on
Comedy and how it's like oh this is a
great time for comedy and [ __ ] because
all those Liberals are getting put down
but it's like dude for [ __ ] hundreds
of years or at least 100 years
[ __ ] the right was the problem about
like abortion and gay marriage
anything Christian decency and square
they were the ultimate Gatekeepers of
like that's not [ __ ] funny and cancel
that yeah like I'm not ready to embrace
you just yet yeah and now that the
[ __ ] now that the left has kind of
taken over that was that was a good
they're over correcting the pit yeah the
pendulum is moving now that the left
kind of did it I got
a spell luck is doing it and they're
like no that's not funny the writes like
who the [ __ ] are you and it's like you
guys have been doing this for a [ __ ]
hunting [ __ ] you guys yeah I mean no one
wants to edit or like censor but there
is a small amount of censorship that's
necessary
back
well I think that like censorship you
know like back in the 90s and [ __ ] and
in the early 2000s you know cussing like
on television wasn't permitted I think
that also limited people uh in a good
way because more artistic things were
derivative so like you would [ __ ]
look at them swearing is a good line to
draw well it's just like at that point
not in comedy I'm talking about in film
or like just television
yeah but swearing was uh that was his
thing that's what got him talking yeah
you got a jerk or something and he got
arrested for it I also loved heroin
loved heroin
no
six
who didn't enjoy heroin back then yeah
it's a cool [ __ ] day and you do some
heroin does this microphone work or no
okay
no because I'm yelling in it you want to
pull it out
that's what she said
all right let's pull it out for a brick
you have brick no I don't want to pull
it out yeah breaks a resource right now
dude [ __ ] Patrick trade me for your
brakes dude
oh man I'll trade you a a a two sheep
and a wood
stick it all the way up
holy [ __ ] idiot unplug it oh my god oh
he's just gonna set it down
all right yeah it looks great no no it
looks good it looks good
um do you let's let's do this let's do
this let me give you a sheep and a wood
for one brick two sheeps two wood one
rock
[Laughter]
take all your cards
who's got Rob
the things you need to repair to make
some treat things
so you guys all have why you have to be
so racist all the time Han sometimes
if I'm acting Chinese
exactly it's not even your ethnicity
no you don't know what my ethnicity is
no I'm English and I'm also Irish and
Ashkenazi Jew you're white you're not I
am almost
it would give me a uh it would get me a
uh it got me a free pass to Israel dude
I'm a [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah take that
Israel program no I I don't want to
because I'm making so much money right
now I think I can do it later but if
they're like hey it's not good isn't it
only at a certain age yeah they cut it
off after 29. it's really they pump it
up to 29. uh it's really your 20s I
think you could do it even I think
actually you could do it in your 30s but
the thing is if you pay money you go to
like [ __ ] Egypt and [ __ ] too
well I think the Jews have had to let me
take it so bad
can you not do that dude
are you coming for me I'm in last place
yeah no not your second you have four
points no ride your cards no I have
nothing you want I have just wood
that's it
I told you I just would you [ __ ]
what do you need
um
all right
ten
what do you know scary
oh it's not no it's not you're fine it's
done
were you done yeah I'm done
and we're gonna leave it I'm gonna keep
my sheep
so if you had to book a Showcase of
awesome Comics five awesome Comics
present company excluded
who would you book and why is it Casey
rocket
he didn't even come to mind
no he was he was in the first place
oh that's nice
I'm enjoying this stuff lately he's
adorable that's great he's got
incredible stuff what about Sam
Jordan Shelby Jordan Shelby's in my five
too
he's uh I like Sullivan Patrick's
Superior Valley what the [ __ ] dude
yeah we are yeah yeah I'm the medium
version of him he's my Pokemon [ __ ]
upgrade
yeah no yeah Dylan's [ __ ] amazing I
just figured and gayer yeah
he's a hundred percent of everything I'm
50 at
God damn you're more of a straight man
though you have that anger and that
scary Edge too yeah you can never have
being a gay
marvelous his dick only goes in
buttholes no he's got his his dick goes
with buttholes too men's buttholes seven
seven
pounds literally last time what happened
it's gonna happen to you again if you
take from it you can attack dude
you gotta do it
told you I told you what was going to
happen why do you have to put it on the
five man it's a part
it's a power game yeah
I'm
stuck
five oh you [ __ ] sucking friends
thank you dude what the hell you really
ruined the game does anybody have brick
no longer do I
I would make a trade at this point
dude [ __ ] you Patrick what the hell is
your [ __ ] problem man
no you're just a [ __ ] dude why did
you have to build my [ __ ] road oh
yeah you [ __ ] me so hard in this game
four
yeah
you're fine you [ __ ] me so bad in this
game dude I [ __ ] hate you
all right let's turn this into 12
drinking game also there we go it's
about time bro 12.
we did it I hate you so much dude two
more towels
miles Johnson and Audrey Scott Ah that's
a good name those are good names who is
that
Casey Audrey Scott it must be Audrey
Scott because she's the only one who
would put herself on that [ __ ] lunch
asked me who do you think in this scene
is great who are you Casey Deans
actually why do you know the Austin
coffee and I said oh are you done
well good job Casey Dean well yeah I
think those are good ones
are so right he's like why would you do
that
he's silly he's one of my favorites
yeah I'm not gonna say it creative [ __ ]
Johnson
bomb
uh hard at shows that comment happens
dying at that we're like how is the
whole crowd collectively not on board
with this
right because because like when you
watch me bombard you're like I get it
but miles you're like what's going on
here
am I because he's black that's a good
one who said that that's a good point
he's just like he's just like so Random
sometimes
what'd you roll
seven yeah he's like wait oh he's like a
where I remember he's like aware of
everything he's like next he's like
thinking seven steps ahead yeah but then
that can be a negative thing if people
were like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait think about that much why are you
rolling the seven at this lower level
did I roll yeah dude yeah you rolled
like a something he's like sometimes two
away some people don't want to be aware
for what we appreciate okay what are you
talking about I feel like people can say
that about you exactly
you think Miles Johnson the silliest boy
in Austin comedy is too aware I love
that silliness too he's just playing
he's like we're here in this room the
economy did this today NASDAQ is going
on and some people are like I don't want
to think about that much you're
projector
yeah I agree I agree I totally agree I
watched him talk about getting ahead
today on stage some audiences are stupid
yeah they don't want to like expand the
horizons and I think miles is a very uh
he provides a complete picture of the
world he's like this is the way the
world is no no miles just wants jokes of
like me and my girlfriend were rolling
disagree with you
are stand up other people's perspective
instead of just being like well I don't
know hey
I'm sorry that I think that miles is
really smart and that he's aware of
everything he is very easy yeah right oh
I farted it smells awful but his gun is
so bad well what you see us yeah give me
the vacuum dude give me the vacuum no
I'm serious that's a great idea you're
gonna say get to put the back
Hans give me the vacuum I farted it
smells horrible
I'm gonna vacuum the part that's outside
dude anybody need water it would work
nine
no that didn't count the things are
tilted no what are you talking that's
eight
are you [ __ ] sucking [ __ ]
so how would you describe miles as
comedy goofy silly yeah it's goofy he's
all creative and very creative
he talks about it six yeah
you're making it sound it's like he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] political comic like you
make him sound like Bill Hicks to where
it's like man he's thinking outside I
don't have to be directly talking about
politics to be aware of the world you
can just be like okay well in that case
I know what you're talking about six
I made a joke tonight on stage about how
uh
I made a joke tonight about how uh I
never know what to do with my left hand
and all the comics were laughing at the
joke
and then I went off stage and they were
like it felt like the crowd didn't know
what you were talking about because they
don't get that that you're you know
you're a comic so you're constantly
thinking about that the crowd was kind
of like oh okay that's like a thing of
yours and I was like okay
I figured the crowd would just get that
half of the crowd kind of did
that's it
Oh I thought that was coming from the
computer that scared the [ __ ] out no my
God you know who's really hot [ __ ]
Larry David's daughter
yeah okay
Larry David's daughter is smoking hot
that's what I roll that's all I care
about
so uh
do you think that uh
miles Johnson do you think that Nick
Roche is just like the White Version
Nick roach is [ __ ] hilarious that's a
good that's a good yeah no I'll say that
no silly one-liner comic he's like so
goofy it's funny yeah
six six six
it's like awkward and he's like that's
who it is
what'd you get what'd you get pull it
out you already saw it no dude if you're
still going then it doesn't count
anybody have a sheep
no [ __ ] you
I'll give you one in a week for a sheep
I bet she would
you Doug yeah
yeah that's what I thought you idiot
[ __ ] loser
I thought four four was his roast
yeah yeah yeah Nick Roche is an
all-around gem
when they did the uh when Adam lucky did
the Austin comedy competition he did a
set at spider house against Chris Reese
and just the two of them were like sets
of the night in my opinion because Nick
Roche did had like the best [ __ ] set
I've ever seen him have I know so
glorious but then Chris Reese not done
like the same level like of great but it
was crowd work so it was more off the
top of his head so he only won by that
like [ __ ] nudge of like Nick was
written out and it was great but Chris
was off the top of his head grade
which is like a little harder sometimes
by a little bit but it was the best like
the two of them
they killed it yeah
I saw Nick Roche
go up at uh in like uh
north of Dallas
play now and he's just like so awkward
and weird
no
so I forgot he was so weird yeah I think
it's very interrupting I just want to
make sure your fans were hearing you bro
um maybe after my sentence is done sheep
what'd you wrong for haunts you can go
did you bring him up there with you yes
does it feel good to give young Comics
opportunities like that
I don't know why that was funny I'm
asking an Earnest I don't really feel
like
yeah I forgot what I was gonna say
necklace very funny
got a big dick so awkward and dumb and
weird he's got a big penis
do y'all know that
is turning to be a sound guy at the
creek oh really
four
hello
is your mic on
um
does anybody need weight Dear Mama wheat
for ore or brick Oh Mama need that wheat
any brick or wheat no I'll give two
wheat for a brick or two weeks I'm gonna
give you [ __ ] hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello
sorry what
does anybody need wood
you know I forgot that I traded in four
wood earlier and I realized that I'm on
a wood Port I'm [ __ ]
I'm going to trade in four wood for a
sheep sheep
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh dude
that was awesome
[Laughter]
he's a [ __ ] man so what do you think
about it
I think Ukraine should have been in the
World Cup this year they deserved a shot
I think it's unfortunate I think they
got held up somewhere
[Laughter]
if Russia is going to be in the World
Cup [ __ ] who's [ __ ] Ukraine in
there come on yeah we should have a
Russia versus Ukraine and the World Cup
she put an ore instead of a tree
what the [ __ ] do you say to me
shut up dude
I [ __ ] place the right cards he's
trying to help you I think no he didn't
no I didn't what'd you roll I placed a
[ __ ] tree it was the only truth
shut up dude I'm so [ __ ]
pontificating
yo does anybody want to trade for like a
[ __ ] sheep I think I need a sheep
I'm not trading nobody's watching us
right now
seven
I love all sounds amazing Scott seven
accounts
six sixy wig see you guys are [ __ ] me
with that friend
what's that brick what's that uh [ __ ]
what's hagridon
yeah
I love you Andre dude
got a bogey on your six
so do you think that uh
the
uh
the economy should be more centered
around like
the same [ __ ]
this is Texas we drive cars I think
American people American moms have to
just Ferry their kids around everywhere
it's like they just have to be an Uber
driver we're going to do everything
we could
yeah yeah
what dude you know like a little you two
dude a little Bon Jovi
that's a good song
11. it was a ten I don't know it's
Sunday oh thank you Sunday a song about
the University of Texas Tower shooting
is it no it's about an Irish
uprising
anybody need wheat nope nope nobody ever
needs weed you can go to the spot in the
tower where he shot all those people
that's great have you been there yeah
that was the first thing I did
I was so happy I bet it was you [ __ ]
psychopath when I first got to Texas I
stopped in Dallas to see where oh my God
I went to Waco Texas to see the Branch
Davidian company if anybody sees him
reading Catcher in the Rye [ __ ] shoot
him just shoot Patrick yeah that's so
cool because that's like a lot of gun
violence in Texas yeah right yeah we
have our rights but we have to pay for
them yeah oh it's good to honor our
fallen heroes in that time is like what
it could have been worth it last year
it's good to repair us back to your
roots Greg Abbott said it could have
been working because
that's three that's three you just need
to do a roll out of the room he said
that if you're just like undid the
breaks and just boom Colorado legalized
weed like four years ago
but cute nightclub eight nine years ago
nightclub just got shot up in Colorado
so for what weed's not the same thing so
how how good is this video
90th
uh Columbine
James Holmes the movie theater now this
gay nightclub College yeah what's up
Colorado Colorado
shootings Columbine yeah they're famous
for it
Aurora Q nightclub
I guess because they're out in the west
they have a lot of remnants of like
cowboy culture mountains
Mountaineers the mountains I wasn't I
spent I spent uh a week in Colorado
um two years ago this month I bet you
did the loser I [ __ ] loved it I loved
Colorado
but I could see myself losing my mind
there
like all work and no play makes Patrick
a dull boy like that kind of just
sitting in the mountains you know being
to yourself
yeah it's isolation yeah
if you guys get Aviation sickness
I didn't but yeah that was very much
like a thing that everyone warned me
about like everybody was very much like
hey bear like be careful didn't I got
lucky
I took a fat [ __ ] it always makes me
[ __ ] when I go in the morning
yeah I take a huge [ __ ] like as soon as
I get up there for some reason I just
take a giant chip like as big as my
forearm it happens every time without
fail
yeah
there you go
do you have cigarettes dad
the hell
yeah
wait a second
David dude
give it to me Patrick don't be an
[ __ ] it says
he would have gone much smoother than
you just said
yeah
surroundings breath that's so mean
to say to an adult your surroundings bro
yo it would have gone smoother
thing
nothing actually okay yeah that works
there
so what do you think about uh what's
another question what do you think about
MMA ah I wish I knew names more do you
think it's good to know or do you think
it's yeah
name four Champions right now
no right now
exactly is
oh yeah
who beat Oliveira [ __ ] the beach
brother
well the best part of MMA isn't the
trivia or like memorizing names you
should see the emotions and the glory
somebody hand me a word absolutely and
you know what I think got me really into
it
is uh
recently the UFC released a bunch of
freak fights on YouTube
and
just the sheer amount of content
so we'll go back and watch
just hours of fights so I got really
into it by watching reruns because I've
I've never been someone who can like
before to just watch a pay-per-view well
I found that as I've uh been watching a
lot of like videos online I've I don't
like watching movies or TV shows as much
as I watch I like sporting events or
like
uh something real like informational or
like like someone being authentic that's
what I think I improve most and there's
nothing more on that authentic than two
people fighting and trying to hurt each
other it's like no matter what [ __ ]
you're going through you have to pay
attention and do that so I think there's
so much complexity you can see in
reality and you can see six layers deep
as opposed to just like a TV show where
they're like this guy's crying because
this girl hit him or whatever so it's
actually there's more complexity to it
what's cool though if you boil down to
the fight itself most of the time those
people respect the [ __ ] out of each
other like they appreciate what they're
doing like they're beating the [ __ ] out
of each other but they respected
[Music]
right
you know good reasons and getting the
best at it like if you do it for bad
reasons it's hard to get good at it but
then also there are people that [ __ ]
genuinely hate each other and those
fights are awesome too yeah I mean if
you're really good at [ __ ] people up
you're gonna you know be really good
hating people it's like it's a skill I
thought Connor clearly just Conor
McGregor did the best job of pissing
people off and making it feel like it
was an anxiety driven fight but he
really didn't give a [ __ ] he was just
doing it for this
Showmanship and like building up his
persona but what about someone like GSP
who doesn't have to talk any [ __ ] yes
GSP is my favorite fighter of all time
so I mean it's good to have both I think
like as soon as you get [ __ ] there I
will [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking punch you dude
don't [ __ ] do it dude don't you put
that down dude I swear it's like it's
happening in reality
fighting just be
a thing that's fine
I hate you dude
like in your sphere of reality
you gotta give me two enough to build
two roads so I can beat Patrick to this
place I need uh
I need a brick okay so who's gonna give
me a break right now what do you need
what do you need guys oh I need to roll
first hold on
oh yeah you all know the rules I'm an
idiot [ __ ] suck a dick
uh let me go ahead and get
it hold on now
and do this
trade in that
for an or
I'm going to upgrade a city here
put down two rocks and three wheat it's
three rocks no I put down three rocks
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you man
they see him drunk enough that I can get
over there
piece of [ __ ] I'm not that broke
right he's just [ __ ]
so smart dude he wants brick
sheep they have sheep I have meat
till the seven people are watching are
gonna get you fired for saying
that would be ridiculous that's what you
would think dude everyone at Verizon
Wireless knows I'm cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
[ __ ] you
how do you have a brick
I have wheat
oh wait I didn't build my room I put
down a week
again I did I did what happened
I would not lie
[Music]
um nine okay
what do you think is the best social
media app to put your fizzle stand up
Bizzle I mean
well Casey Rockets blowing up on Tick
Tock while Dino and stanfeld just blow
up hard on Instagram with one of his
class jokes he did what happened
what happened I got like 5 000 followers
and like a million likes on one of his
Clips
a video that has five million views
really yeah where uh it says like uh
this is breaking news oh yeah if you go
with us 5 million it's just you're gay
[Laughter]
that's awesome dude I mean I saw that I
thought it was just my dad waking me up
how many followers did you get from it I
thought it was my football coach dude
oh my God
yeah five yeah Instagram but the thing
is like Dean's bit was like
um
it was like his personality and he was
like going along into it and he was like
describing like he's like this is my
character and it was like a joke that
really
uh fit what he was trying to put out
right right
it really did
captured he was like a whole picture
with one joke so I think that was a
better joke it's funny because knowing
him I literally like 10 000 followers
and those people are going to be
invested in him now yeah
this is a white country and he does a
lot of cool stuff like catfishing
working with race cars so people when
they see that clip they go to this page
and then they see a whole axis of
material where they're like oh if I
follow this guy and invest in him like
I'm gonna get something out of it
because he constantly puts out
yeah social media is a part of his life
he knows how to incorporate it for
it's like a useful skill like some
people don't have that urge to post
that's
not the end-all be-all but it is a
helpful thing if you can Master it I
definitely need to get better at it you
don't post at all all I have is roasts
but it's just everything I [ __ ] post
is Rose no yeah dude I haven't been
roasting for like a month now and I'm
getting way better at comedy well for a
longest time too I just I think my
materials
I'm like this doesn't represent me yet
right I don't want to just put stuff out
there and look like a shitty comic yeah
but I've had some sets lately where I'm
like I could put this up right if I uh
the time
no I mean but it's also about like
fitting the right thing like Dean did
that so well with his clip so so that's
the whole part the unfortunate thing is
that now that it's out there but the
good thing is that it's a sort of joke
about I didn't see this clip I'm gonna
have to watch this later tonight it's
gonna have to happen
whoa nice
should I have two one
does anybody have a rock or brick
catch your mama
wood or wheat no
what are we no
for an orc no
give you a wheat no I'll give you a wood
in a week hell no
suck a dick dude
can you just [ __ ] put it down like a
regular person
yeah but if you're like
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no no no no
you should build that
you gotta help Gareth oh I hate you so
much
I [ __ ] hate you so much what is your
problem dude what's your [ __ ] problem
tonight the [ __ ] is your problem dude
no I'm not
uh let's see
I literally
I can build on it I can't even build on
the desert dude
[Music]
no I'm just sitting here now you son of
a [ __ ] dude you're not doing bad no
there's nothing I can do you can come
back
no I [ __ ] I'm so mad
I hate you so much
because you first [ __ ] me up
so bad
upgrade your shirt oh my God you can
still build cities
dude [ __ ] I hate you all yo so much
you can get six victory points just buy
development cards from here on
Patrick what do you think about uh
capitalism
capitalism
uh
I don't know eventually where does it
where does it lead to the worst oh
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I know right eventually we're gonna have
to do something well eventually like the
big the big name wins in capitalism and
then they start saving money and
offering the lowest valued [ __ ]
so then it's you know
I want to just [ __ ] punch you I don't
know how I feel about capitalism because
I'd be interested what's the other
options America has socialism being more
sharing yeah socialism I'd like to try
it if it fails then we can all say hey
it failed let's restart yeah but we're
not even life is really life is really
kindergarten but we pretend it isn't we
pretend we're a college that's what I'm
saying it's all kindergarten we can
[ __ ] fight I was just kidding we can
[ __ ] around and find out let's try
socialism throw Bernie in there for a
bit Yeah but say this what if we threw
like FDR well that's what I'm saying
earlier about like what if we had a
council before when America was actually
great
exactly but imagine instead of one
president imagine if you had 40 people
counseling America
what percentage of those 40 people would
be pedophiles
there's a lot of pedophiles in America
oh yeah come outside what do you rolling
[Laughter]
he [ __ ] [ __ ] me over I'm gonna fart
on him
okay
stop being so American
you're a mayor kid dude I don't act like
it though
sheet for Brick
your farting doesn't just affect Patrick
you won't do one sheep for one brick two
wood I don't have any wood no or thank
you or forever so what are you doing
he's got Brooke
yes
do you want to trade no
I'm suspicious you had a lot of Devonta
cards
oh yeah [ __ ] you do
what are you guys up to look at that
yeah lapel mics
thank you
no re-roll no yeah it's out of the thing
all right
we just rolled another six exactly
exactly here we go all right same colors
keep talking uh
onomatopoeia [ __ ] you Hans you suck you
suck
you can't find it I think I got it oh
yeah
[Music]
are there people still in the Trap
it's more for posterity's sake
sorry
there's no life in his eyes oh no I have
pontification seven
there's no wife in my uh what the [ __ ]
dude because you got this hey can you
pass the THC you didn't have to bring
that up
you mean the CBD the THC no CBD it's all
CBD it's all CBD
[ __ ] I gotta delete my LinkedIn
[Laughter]
you guys aren't all in on comedy
uh Holland's you know take us on tour so
we can pay our rent and then yeah we'll
be fine after that well I don't think
you should rely on me
yeah [ __ ] you Quan so you get me fired
is that just William Montgomery under a
weird bot name
I wish if William Montgomery what do you
guys think about cornbread
that was a horrible last time I talked
to William Montgomery I was about to go
up on a roast and I was going against a
girl and he said how are you feeling and
I was like ah well she's you know a
small cute girl so I feel like she's
probably gonna win
anyone I don't like that you said that
and he just ran away he's just walking
he's just [ __ ] around the dude's wild
I loved him to death he was
he's my favorite uh comic other than
Casey in the Austin scene yeah like by
far but I think he's my favorite also in
general like uh [ __ ] William dude
um
why don't you go play Katan with Willian
oh oh I'm sorry Hans you know since
William invite you to play Katan with
him no Holland's you're you're a good
friend okay there's a difference here uh
when I met will I think there was uh
[Laughter]
it was really
I'm good for
it wow look at that what are you on
that's nice that's a good [ __ ] rig
I wish I had that one shut up dude
that's what I said earlier that's what I
was saying he didn't say you're funny
you want to do this oh no oh you didn't
say it funny oh that was funny I'm a big
[ __ ] big [ __ ] idiot [ __ ] you [ __ ]
I was talking to me you do marijuana no
more what is your [ __ ] what do you need
the most how can I [ __ ] you oh my God
yes David yeah
you already gave me coven once
um Hans what should I put this on to
[ __ ] over Patrick the mix
it was good
this is good but that's you
have a port on anything only on this oh
my God are you okay do you have a drink
there's a port on the hay no no I want
to [ __ ] over Patrick the most so this is
true I have two on that 11. and the six
is good but two of them
but I have a knight so if you put it on
there I'm just gonna move it just put it
right here okay give me your [ __ ] you
[ __ ] idiot
oh okay oh that was good for me no
thanks dude yeah little hits
David no
um
here you go Bud go get him
10.
10. okay do you mean two of them sheep
that's what I'm talking about
talking about them sheep people
I need them sheets
apart so bad
you just got used to letting it out no I
have I'm so gassy dude
I'm a gassy man
a gassy little boy uh yeah dude I could
fill up a helium balloon
the Zeppelin who wants wood
me what do you want sheep got it
thanks
oh you're done dude anything that [ __ ]
you over you piece of [ __ ]
what have I ever done for you huh
what if I what have I ever done for old
Patrick over here and how you were baby
give me fleas and you're fine and you
[ __ ] block me off and gets on
you son of a [ __ ]
good
no no no no no no don't do that
yeah it's fine
you're an idiot no you're an idiot
you're a [ __ ] idiot dude you're a
giant idiot I almost graduated college
you giant idiot
[ __ ] damn it David
with your knight Army
three
oh
God you get so much out of three
yeah but it's such a hard number to hit
does anybody have a brick and wheat
uh I have either of those things
freaking week I'll give you a brick for
um uh wood
one for one yeah down
you got it
do you think that um
Catholicism so this is gonna be
something I failed sucks ass nude [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
but imagine if there was like a version
of Catholicism where you could still
honor the traditions of the European
nobility and the history it's called the
current British Empire
there's literally no point to it
no that can't happen I must set it one
two three four five six seven
he's more of a threat
Boys Roll six
roll the six
Jesus Christ dude
Gareth what do you think it is about
white people that made them so
successful
dude okay so first off my family founded
the first African-American college
in this country Fisk University fact
swear to god dude that's true
were they legally required
no no no
because of what they did I got all I got
Jewish ancestors and I got cool
ancestors so it all worked out well but
uh white people were trash
10. wow
two sheep
now white people are the worst man like
what else is worse than a white person
there's not much dude I mean they did
bring volcanoes uh Instagram let's
God damn it dude he really needed
nothing really
but two white people the worst thing the
worst thing to a white person other than
a white person oh man I get that now if
they're racist majority of white people
yeah
it's a tough thing because
you can't try to be good at everything
you're never going to catch up that's
why we have [ __ ] punk rock it's all
we can do we can cry we can cry about it
punk rock dude punk rock dude punk rock
is a good shot I like Punk [ __ ] my mom
saw the Ramones
um not as big as a black
that's true
uh who once that's not even funny at all
does anybody want to trade a brick for a
wood
give you David how is it working at the
creek in the cave break for a wood give
you a brick
I have a brick I want a wood it's
actually been a great experience come on
dude you've already [ __ ] me over so
much if you have a wood you should do
that
and how it is like a family there for
that everyone yeah and then you have the
comedians who are this like separate
family I can't even win this is a shot
at the Moon dude just kidding dude from
comedians I'm taking shots
like the headliners it's like you see a
little Slice of Life
yeah
and what do you learn oh that I want to
be on stage more than well that's the
thing it's like working at a comedy club
is sort of all right yeah because you
were working when you should be doing
Mike's comedy shows exactly we're
working during comedy hours and that's
why I'm I am looking for a day job to
sustain the bills because like you said
it is taking up the time I should be but
you're around it so much and there's a
benefit to that you feel the energy and
the gravity toss
that you don't want to join our clan
Clan
let me see my wait okay
hits it before he hands it back that
tells you everything you need to know
about carrotfish no it doesn't no lady
doesn't that keep it simplify a person
to that 100 you're a dirty bong hitter
okay I have I ripped that way too
because both cautioned belongs out I
didn't do anything I never touched that
having a fit anything I touched that was
I touch that to put it away from me
and I win
can you update me to nine
for the next one
I could have gotten seven points dude
I just realized I'm on the two for one
port I could have been using that for a
while huge dumb idiot
what are you doing dude
I can use that for [ __ ]
one two three four
game one-on-one get zero and zero